[Percussion music]
Air team, Call in!
Shamrock, Go!
Borkins, Go!
Cadet Puncheater!
I'm here! I'm sorry, I'm just a bit nervous...
We'll be home before lunch, Rookie.
Yeah... A packed bologna sandwich, a Twix bar...
and a Coke just in case.
You can eat sandwiches on the plane?
cut the chatter! The target is [...]
Coordinates locked,  Fire away!
Fox 3's, away!
[screaming]
Cadet, get a hold of yourself!
[C
[Continues screaming]
Puncheater, eject!
God dammit, Puncheater!
Hey... Did the new guy just die?!
Yes, he did...
Approaching target! Break into aggressive motion!
We're in too close, pull out!
I have you now...
[Beeping Alarms and Explosions]
Son of a bitch!
Hartsling! Come in Major Hartsling!
Hartsling here!
Lance, thank god! You need to come back to HQ
I'm not done here!
It's over... Operation A is a failure.
Come back, Lance.
[growls in frustration]
Shamrock, do you copy?
Yes sir.
We're done here. Operation A is a failure.
[Whirring energy]
What the hell is that?!
Oh no...
[Blasts and explosions]
Shane!
[Blaring alarms]